Michael Flynn as you now know spoke to
the Russian ambassador Sergei Kiss lyac
following Trump's election denied it for
weeks that they had talked about
sanctions ultimately we found out that
that was true and Donald Trump asked for
Michael Flynn's resignation last Monday
we now have learned that it was not just
casual lying that former national
security adviser Michael Flynn
participated in with regard to that
conversation Michael Flynn reportedly
denied to FBI agents in an interview
last month that he had talked about
sanctions with the Russian ambassador
this was of course contradicted by the
ultimately intercepted communications
that our intelligence agencies gathered
that claim to the FBI by Michael Flynn
could put Michael Flynn in legal
jeopardy lying to the FBI is a felony
offense now several officials say well
we don't know if prosecutors would try
to charge him with anything because he
may not have really used the term
sanctions in those communications so it
may not be easy to actually prove it in
a court of law in a literal sense
reminder this is what Martha Stewart did
that landed her in prison she was
suspected of insider trading and that
started an investigation but she was
actually found guilty on felony charges
of conspiracy obstruction of an agency
proceeding and making false statements
to federal investigators that was about
some stock spat what Michael Flynn
allegedly lied to the FBI about relates
to our national sovereignty and security
it is orders of magnitude more serious
than what Martha Stewart did that landed
her in prison and remember Michael Flynn
speaking at the Republican National
Convention about what Hillary did with
her emails right worthy of being locked
up for I mean this is far worse because
it demonstrates some intent there and
lying to the FBI I don't care if you're
in a position of power or not you should
pay some repercussions for that
this is absolutely of huge consequence
now any decision to actually prosecute
Flynn would lie with the Justice
Department and our buddy Jeff Sessions
who is in charge over there spokesman
for Flynn said no risk
to the allegations FBI and Justice
Department asked to comment both have
declined House Republicans oh they don't
see any problem at all let's focus
instead on quietly rolling back
President Obama's work to protect our
planet as I talked about at the
beginning of the show and you might not
have heard about this story involving
Michael Flynn lying to the FBI allegedly
because the timing overlapped would that
bizarre Donald Trump press conference
again distractions if I lied to the FBI
definitely a pat lied to the FBI
we'd be prosecuted and would likely go
to prison
shouldn't Michael Flynn get the same
treatment yep doesn't matter if it's me
or you and Michael Flynn I like how you
you implied that if I was lying to the
FBI even more so than you absolutely
yeah no doubt about that and again you
know the broader and more specific
allegations of the Trump Russia
blackmail dossier continue to be proven
true piece by piece drip by drip not a
conversation about Flynn specifically
but again the Trump team in touch with
Russian officials sanctions were a topic
at varying levels of specificity drip
drip drip soon you're going to have a
bucketful there